OK.
Let's get into your questions, first one is,
hey, David, how will a vaccine before November
1st affect the election?
Even how this is asked needs to be clarified
because there is not going to be a vaccine
before November 1st in the sense that anybody
is really going to be getting it.
The absolute best case scenario would be that
a vaccine approval is announced sometime in
October before the election.
And presumably what that will mean is that
it is an emergency use authorization from
Trump's FDA.
Whether we trust it or not, is a different
question.
It is very unlikely that a full approval for
a vaccine will come in October, although it's
possible.
But either way, the point of Donald Trump
doing this, which I've predicted for months,
that sometime during October it will be we
got it, we got the vaccine.
The point of this will be to associate himself
with getting the vaccine even if the vaccine
is from another country.
As we know, the UK is very far ahead on vaccines
and so are many other countries.
And it is going to be a PR and optics play.
Now, a lot of people are pointing to this
letter that was sent out by the CDC last week,
which I covered, which tells states be ready
to distribute a vaccine by the end of October
or early November.
And there are many who are interpreting that
to mean that there might be hundreds of millions
of doses actually being distributed on that
date.
And that is not actually the likely scenario.
What the letter says is states should have
their plan in place for how to distribute
the vaccine.
By that time, it does not actually suggest
that states will have millions of doses to
distribute by that time.
Now, in terms of let's play it out, Trump
announces a vaccine and says we did it were
the first to do it.
The FDA has determined that this vaccine is
safe and we are issuing an emergency use authorization
and will immediately start sending vaccines
around.
How much of an impact would that have?
First of all, it would be a smaller impact
than in previous elections.
Why?
Because more people than ever are expected
to vote early and to vote absentee, meaning
that even if you don't go and vote early in
person, you will have mailed your absentee
ballot already, meaning that something that
happens on October 15th or 20th or 25th may
well have less of an impact this time around
than it would have in the past.
The other thing is, I don't know that that
many people are going to fall for it.
If you look at more of a qualitative analysis
like the one done by Allan Lichtman, for example,
or or or some other election prediction, here's
the cake gets baked earlier than the middle
of October or November 1st or whatever.
The case may be the only counter to that.
And I do think it's a relevant counter is
that if the election is expected to be close
from an electoral standpoint, even if Biden
wins the popular vote by a few points, as
he well may, you could still have an electoral
victory for Donald Trump based on a few states.
If Donald Trump's announcement of a vaccine
emergency use authorization on October 25th,
for example, shifts just one percent of the
value of the votes in some states, it is conceivable
mathematically that that would shift the results
from Joe Biden to Donald Trump.
And so that's why we need to anticipate that
this is going to happen, because I've been
predicting it for months.
We need to anticipate that the voter suppression
that is likely to be done is not going to
figure into the polls that the voter purges,
that the messing with the post office.
None of this stuff is going to be in the polling
numbers.
And thus we need to do everything we can to
get out the vote to understand that even in
blue states, we need to run up the score,
even in red states that Biden will lose.
We need to get as many votes for Biden as
possible to have the most overwhelming possible
popular vote victory in order to make it more
difficult.
That's all we're trying to do.
We're trying to make it more difficult for
a court if it comes down to a court saying
you can keep counting absentee ballots or
you have to stop.
That it makes the decision more difficult
for them.
If the popular vote is overwhelming in favor
of Joe Biden, I do predict that sometime between
October 20th and November 1st, the White House
is going to send Trump to some facility, maybe
a pharmacy.
Listen, this guy's depraved.
I could imagine him going to SEVIS and announcing
we are issuing an emergency use authorization
for a corona virus vaccine.
There will be no such vaccine at that CBS.
It will be a photo op.
And I worry that it could actually convince
one or two percent of the population in some
states and it would be very, very bad for
Joe Biden.
So let's
be ready.